hey here's something it's been a very
serious day election results I just in
in a few minutes here I want to deal
with something less serious but
extraordinarily annoying CVS has to do
something about their receipts CVS of
the pharmacy chain is known for really
long paper receipts like comically long
and I was there the other day and was
given I think I bought deodorant before
my trip out to politican and I got a
receipt that was like three feet long
and then I started googling this and it
turns out that some people have actually
received receipts at CVS that are almost
6 feet long in some cases some people
posting them to social media buying just
an item or two and getting receipts
almost 6 feet long can't we just stop
this like has CVS issued any kind of
statement about why this is something
they're doing I've seen nothing about
sort of a defense of 6 foot long
receipts it's a disgusting waste of
paper it is comical but it's absolutely
and totally ridiculous and I don't know
if it's you know is it you know how
Starbucks will some I don't know because
I don't go to Starbucks but I've seen on
the internet that Starbucks employees
will sometimes misspelled names on
people's cups even seemingly like easy
to spell names and I wonder is that a
marketing ploy because they know people
will post the pictures and it becomes
this funny thing and oh yeah I should go
to Starbucks and get one of those $7
Frappuccino things or whatever but if
CVS is doing this as a marketing ploy
it's one that's terrible for the
environment given how much paper they
are wasting on this stuff and we talked
about saving the environment by getting
rid of plastic straws and saving the
environment by not wasting food do we
really need multi footlong receipts from
CVS for any dumb purchase and and as if
as if they're not doing enough damage
with with just that the the paper cup
thing at Starbucks also has an
environmental cost it's easy to say well
the Starbucks one has no environmental
cost those paper coffee cups the way
that they prevent the coffee
from making the paper soggy is that they
have a liner and that liner is of
dubious recyclability
so anyway I don't go to Starbucks so I
don't really care about that one but I
might have to reconsider my CVS trips if
they keep giving me six foot long
receipts in some places now actually
we'll ask you do you want your receipt
and if you say yes they press a button
and it prints and if you say no they
don't even give you a small receipt I
would like to see CVS go in that
direction but if you actually believe
that this is a marketing ploy to get
people talking about it let me know
because that would be in some in some
sense it's almost kind of brilliant